[Music]
corporate social responsibility or CSR
is everywhere which company now doesn't
have CSR all the major banks that that
screwed America in the financial crisis
and the world that sold out our economy
and and tried to make a killing selling
toxic mortgage products and didn't
didn't come clean to the American people
or regulated about what was going on
paid billions of dollars in fines for
fraud almost all those banks like most
American companies have CSR departments
and they'll go and they'll do some you
know they'll devils they'll do something
with shovels they'll do something with
some poor contrary they'll go to some
community and they'll even teach like a
financial literacy class like you know
don't don't fall prey to it's a
financial fraud of the kind that we
perpetrate it and this whole idea that
you can sell kids poisonous drinks that
give them diabetes while making a
playground that you can build up to the
Dakota pipeline or invest in Dakota
pipeline while sponsoring a climate
change gathering with your CSR that you
can you know push for a health care
system that only gives people benefits
if they work 30 hours a week
thus tempting many employers to only
employ people 29 hours a week and then
say you're in the in the business of
empowering workers or being you know the
best first job in America or whatever
you know the reality is many many
companies are trying to fight on both
sides of a war in their main operation
in their lobbying activities they are
pushing for an America that is merciless
and then understanding the need to brand
themselves understanding the need to you
know soothe a little bit of the public
anger in this age of rage they give a
little back they throw some scraps at us
and what is so sad is that all too often
it works
conscious capitalism that's a good one
again it's this idea that we can make
capitalism more conscious more humane
simply by wishing it or so whereas in
fact the problem with our brand of
market capitalism in America in 2018 is
that as a capitalism purely driven by
the needs of shareholders in and and
that investors needs have come to so
predominate that that the needs of
communities of workers of employees of
those companies and various other
stakeholders are completely marginalized
and until we change that structure
simply calling for capitalism to be more
conscious doesn't really work I mean the
the you know conscious capitalism is
supposed to describe Whole Foods for
example until you know it got taken over
by a private equity firm then you got a
word like innovation we talked about
innovation innovation is is treated as
its own as its own good just a more
innovate innovation and if everybody's
got to innovate well innovators means
make things new and here's the problem
we've done a tremendous amount of
innovation in America over the last
generation what we didn't get a lot of
out of that innovation was progress if
progress is defined as most people's
lives getting better in fact in the era
of innovation we've also seen the odds
of social mobility of out earning your
parents for example fall from ninety
percent to 50 percent a crapshoot right
so yeah great we have a lot of new stuff
a lot of new has come to light as
that as they said in that movie but the
reality is that hasn't gotten people
paid more that hasn't made people's
lives more stable that hasn't helped
people afford housing that hasn't helped
people educate their kids better so we
had a lot of innovation but it's not the
same as progress and progress is the
more important of the two the private
sector is useful for many many things
and it will always be the lion's share
of our economy I'm happy Frank having
been to countries where there are
government-run Airlines they're not very
good I'm happy that we have private air
travel in this country I think you know
it's in general there I mean no one look
at something
it's not the best but you know I'm happy
to have that be something what's done
privately I'm very happy the government
didn't make my iPhone you know I think
we have a heritage in this country of
private enterprise and private endeavor
that is at its best
creative that builds things that makes
life better for people and none of what
I argue is to suggest that that should
go away what I argue is that our private
enterprise at its best has always sat on
a foundation of certain institutions
that we share in common it's hard to
imagine building a company like Apple
without thinking about public schools in
America all the Apple employees who went
to them all the people who went to them
and invented technologies that were used
in what Apple builds all the people who
were educated by teachers who themselves
went to public school whether or not
those people went to public school it is
hard to think about any worthy private
thing in American life that has been
built without a heavy reliance on the
institutions we share in common and so
we our responsibility to tend to that
garden and to make sure those things are
healthy and in recent years that
relationship has simply got out of whack
private endeavor has continued
flourished profits are our soaring
innovation is soaring but it has stopped
working for most people and I say in the
book a successful society is a progress
machine into one side goes the inputs of
innovation and fortuitous developments
and on the other side comes out shared
progress and that machine is just broken
down and we just need to fix that
machine so that when good things happen
to us people's lives get better it's
that simple
[Music]